this whole lean methodology doesn't
change anything about funding other than
if you actually do some of this by the
time you walk into an investor
you're a ton smarter than most of the
other people they've seen so now instead
of just presenting an idea you say hey
listen here was my original hypothesis
and here's what we thought customers and
vcs might you know be looking at their
iphone or maybe paying attention and
then you go but you know what i spoke to
20 people it was a stupid idea what why
are you here well because then you know
once i understood that
here's what we did next oh that's kind
of interesting i was just about to tell
you how come you didn't do next yes and
then we spoke to another 20 people or we
got the site up and we had 3 000 people
wow 3 000 that's pretty interesting yeah
but then we found they wouldn't monetize
whoa this is kind of an interesting
story well what did you do then well we
changed the product and then we realized
that this was the real customer segment
here and now we have like 5 000 people
but you know 90 of them are converting
all iphones are dropped people are
leaning forward in the desk and now the
sudden this is a lot more interesting
conversation than it was of hey i have
an idea for a new website or not now by
the way if you're a serial entrepreneur
or you're famous or you've done
something before you can get a meeting
anywhere right with most vcs but really
what makes the conversation interesting
is you've actually de-risked a ton of
the business by doing a series of
experiments on your own nickel rather
than expecting people to pay for you to
go do that
you